In 2001, Danish political
scientist Bjorn Lomborg burst
onto the international scene with
his bestselling and controversial
book, The Skeptical
Environmentalist.
The one time member of Greenpeace
said that climate change is real and
that human activity is clearly
contributing to it.
But he said the best science
didn't support the apocalyptic
visions put forth by people like
Earth in the Balance, author and
former Vice President Al Gore.
Lomborg went on to create the
Copenhagen Consensus, a
think tank that applies cost benefit
analysis to problems facing
the global poor and works with
Nobel laureates, policymakers,
philanthropists and researchers
to develop pragmatic, relatively
low cost solutions to issues
such as tuberculosis, malaria,
lack of education and lack of
access to food.
His new book is called Best
Things First, and it presents
what Lomborg says are the 12
most efficient solutions for
the world's poorest people.
He argues that for about $35 billion
a year, a little more than half
of what the US spends annually on
humanitarian aid, these
policies would save 4.2
million lives and generate
an extra $1.1 trillion
in value every year.
Reason caught up with Lomborg in
New York City during the latest
meeting of the United Nations
General Assembly.
We talked about best things first
and why politicians and the media
continue to fixate on the
possibility of future climate
apocalypse rather than helping
the global poor in the here and
now.
Bjorn Lomborg, thanks for talking to
us.
It's great to be here. Thank you.
Let's start off by talking about
your new book, Best Things First,
which is based on the Copenhagen
Consensus project that you've
developed over the past couple of
decades. First.
What is the Copenhagen Consensus?
So we're really a very small think
tank that work with hundreds
of the world's top economists to ask
very simple question How
do you get the biggest bang for your
buck? Look, there are lots
of stuff you can do.
Not all of it is equally good.
So we simply try to sort of push for
the really smart things you can do
for whatever it is that you want to
achieve. Do you want to get better
health care or do you want to do
something about global warming?
Or do you want to do good for the
world? The last the latter
thing is what this book is about.
It basically asks a very simple
question If you're going to spend an
extra dollar or preferably a couple
hundred million dollars or
something, where can you get a lot
of bang for your buck?
Right. So the subtitle is The 12
Most Efficient Solutions
for the World's Poorest and
Our Global Sustainable Development
Goals Promises.
First, what are the Sustainable
Development goals
that were hashed out in 2015
by the United Nations?
So they were essentially, you know,
the UN's attempt to try to say,
what should we do for the world?
What should we promise for the next
15 years from 2016 to
2030?
So in 2023, we're not halfway
sorry. We're at half time for these
promises, but nowhere near halfway.
So we started out
saying, what should we promise?
And obviously you want to, you know,
reduce poverty or actually they
went so far as to say, get rid of
poverty.
We should also reduce hunger,
actually get rid of hunger, or we
should also fix war.
We should fix corruption, we should
fix climate change, We should fix
education.
But it ended up being
essentially an almost endless
list of promises to do all
good things in the world and make
sure that people get organic apples
and know about indigenous people
and have community gardens and the
whole shebang.
Yeah, it's a very beautiful list of
all the stuff that you would ever
want if you if money
was no object.
But it is.
And U.N.
Secretary General Antonio Guterres,
he's calling for a $500
billion kind of global stimulus
project.
You think that's generally wasteful
and unrealistic?
He's focusing mostly on
renewable energy, universal
social protection and job creation.
Why is that misguided?
Well, so first of all, you're not
going to get people to give half a
trillion dollars more to a project
that's failing.
So if you have a project where you
promised everything, then after
seven and a half years ago, wow, we
didn't make it give us more money.
That doesn't really sound very
reassuring. But also, what you have
to realize is if you're actually
going to deliver on all of the
things you promised, half a trillion
dollars is not going to cut it.
You will need somewhere between
10 and $15 trillion
to deliver all the things we
promised. And of course, that's
the same amount of money that all
the governments in the world
are right now raising in taxes.
Essentially, the argument is,
if we want it to deliver on
everything we promised back in 2015,
we'd have to double all global
taxes.